[Applause]
through weakness and incompetence Joe
Biden has brought us to the brink of
World War III we're at the brink of
World War III just in case anybody
doesn't know it as president I will
bring back peace through strength peace
through strength would have never
happened
If I Was President there would not have
been a war with Russia in Ukraine zero
chance that Lindsay would be happy with
that that's better than any alternative
wouldn't have happened
and I will say this even now despite
tremendous loss of lives and destruction
of much of that country I would have a
peace deal negotiated within 24 hours
you could make a peace deal you could
make a deal
for both right now 24 hours that deal
could be done that deal is waiting to be
done but there's nobody to do it to
protect Americans from the threat of
hypersonic missiles and nuclear weapons
I will build state of the art Next
Generation missile defense shields
[Applause]